the hell are you doing I thought we've
got so sorry I thought it up more time
I'm not the man you think I am I don't
build our city my family and I wasn't
the only one mr. clean did your father
survive an accident
just rest that
survive
has been unmasked as billionaire Robert
queen
Robert was marooned on an island when
his boat went down in the Pacific an
accident that ended with the tragic
Genesis son Oliver Robert Queen was
thought dead when excuse me I'm
receiving word Dinah Laurel Lance always
trying to save the world hey if I don't
try and say that yeah well
[Music]
why is it always so difficult to choose
very what is it it's
Laurel Lance
hey youtubers is Charlie so huge news
big teaser bomb dropped for arrow 100th
episode couple people we haven't seen in
a while coming back not in flashbacks
and not because of flashpoint so this is
gonna be a breakdown this is so funny
how everybody's just being super casual
mark Guggenheim's like no flashbacks no
flash point read-through of the hundreds
episode and just you know if you were to
just to casually look at this it would
just be like oh you know this is nice
there reading the hundredth episode it's
a big deal for the show it's episode
eight this year meaning that it's gonna
happen during the big four night
crossover so already there's a lot of
really cool stuff that's probably going
to be happening just because those
episodes tend to be really huge fan
service and a lot of fun but when you
zoom in just a little bit and you look a
little closer you see Robert Queen who
is that in the background next to
Stephen Amell just reading his bottle of
water just casually like it's no big
deal
so then you think about that Marc
Guggenheim quote no flashbacks no flash
point meaning that this isn't going to
be season one Robert Queen from before
he blew his brains out so there's no way
he survived the island earth one Robert
Queen is completely dead and no flash
point means that you know he isn't
mysteriously brought back because of
what Barry did so there is no earth one
Robert Queen anymore
so you kind of see where I'm going with
this this is earth to Robert Queen who
became the arrow on his earth whereas
his son Oliver on that earth is believed
to be dead now beyond him being unmasked
during season two on earth two we really
don't know what happened to earth to
Robert Queen he presumably continued to
be the vigilante on that earth but
they've been saying about season five
about how they're bringing it all the
way back to season one so because it's
an anniversary episode and it's
important though matically to the main
arc of the season it makes sense that
they would let Oliver meet his father
who would be alive like he would know
that a version of his father was alive
out there and saw him live to become the
arrow and make his city better so they
haven't revealed an official description
for the episode so we don't know what
the conflict is going to be because that
would kind of spoil the big four night
crossover but the
other side of that too if earth to
robert queen is coming for the hundredth
episode it would make sense the Katie
Cassidy would guess star she's already
guest starting his flashback Laurel in a
couple episodes so 100th episode if
they're bringing earth to Robert Queen
wouldn't they also try to bring earth to
black siren so that Oliver would meet a
more comic book II version of Black
Canary who you know we don't know she
might still be really evil she was
really evil the last time we saw so
unless she has done a 180 she's still
gonna be a pretty big villain maybe
she'll even be a part of the Legion of
Doom just remains to be seen I just feel
like if Oliver's gonna be having this
special moment with his father who is
the green arrow of his earth like they
can kind of compare notes like oh my god
I can't believe you're alive really
hardcore family moment it'll probably be
pretty funny too but whatever's
happening he will probably be around in
present-day because they're saying this
isn't a flashback he'll be around in
present-day
for the duration of the episode so it'll
be like a green arrow squared team-up
but you know that says nothing about who
the big villains gonna be it would be
really awesome if black siren as part of
that so that Oliver has a chance to run
into her and you can have like that big
WTF reaction like oh my god she's a
freaking metahuman and Katie Cassidy
gets to wear her villain makeup and blow
some stuff up have a lot of fun but
whatever happens during the episode I
feel like Robert Queen will go back to
earth-2 when the big adventure is done
and so probably would black siren-like
all the earth to people would go back to
their earth or on to legends of tomorrow
based on where the four night crossover
goes after arrow because if you thought
that it was going to be fanservice
because it's the hundredth episode and
that's really what hundreds to hundreds
episodes are for just really fun
fanservice just like the most comic book
II thing you could possibly think up but
because it's during the four night
crossover it just gets exponentially
more awesome so whatever your brain can
imagine it's probably going to be even
better but let me know in the comments
what do you think it is that brings
earth to Robert Queen to earth one
because if he's the vigilante on earth 2
that means he adds a lot of these same
problems so what if it has something to
do with black siren or one of the other
villains from earth 2 coming to earth
one in Robert Queen chasing them there
because otherwise I feel like there's
not much of a reason for him to come to
earth one other
than fanservice so whatever the reason
is who cares it's gonna be awesome
seeing Oliver try to deal with the idea
of his father's doppelganger he's kind
of dealt with it I think he's still
dealing with laurels death so if he were
to see her again - he would probably
just [ __ ] his pants but either way it's
gonna be awesome I can't wait to see it
these are the kind of teasers that they
need to be dropping before arrow season
five things to get you really excited
like earth to Robert Queen coming to
earth one and kicking some ass with
Oliver maybe kickin Oliver zas a little
bit - but I have a feeling that even if
it starts off kind of contentious like
they don't know what to think of each
other they will totally be Bros by the
end of the episode but if you guys
didn't know just to go around the circle
here the other people that are sitting
here the person that's sitting next to
Thea right here is the Ragman character
that's just what he looks like when he's
not wearing his costume obviously you
know mr. terrific
you know Felicity this right here is the
wild dog character and there are
obviously other people sitting around
the table that you just can't see like
sandwich guy here kind of looks like
Diggle maybe and then you have all these
seats right here like Marc Guggenheim is
the guy taking the picture so they're
like a couple other people that are
sitting outside of the frame but more
good news there's new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video it's just a copy of the flash
blu-ray so what's gonna happen is is
they'll be some more Marvel DC if you
guys have any DC bonus videos you guys
want me to do this weekend just let me
know in the comments while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
my last big flash trailer video and you
can click here for my Ghost Rider
episode 1 video from agents of shield
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight